but a plane went down like in the trees
above my house and crashed into the
crashed into the townhouse unit right
next door it sounded like a garbage
truck had dropped a dumpster really hard
and then ran into the side of the
building that's what I assumed had
happened
kissa lodge like right in front of my
front door
and to know that I could have just
ceased so they've been taken out by a
plane you know I'm sorry for laughing
because I know that people are seriously
injured in this but I mean I feel really
lucky to be you know to be unscathed it
literally happened about a thousand feet
away from me
there was about a ten foot tall by 10
foot wide hole in the building the
bricks had fallen there were no signs of
fire or an explosion at all there was no
black or charred elements to it
it just looked to be solely an impact
I'm feeling very lucky it was you know
too close for comfort that close you can
it causes a concern for everyone around
here we we hear and feel the aircraft's
landing on a daily basis
[Music]
you
you